the Keystone XL pipeline is a 2,000 mile
funnel that would pump oil from the
Canadian tar sands south to the
refineries on the US Gulf Coast if the
5.3 billion dollar pipeline is approved
what does that mean for jobs will create
about 42,000 direct and indirect jobs
nationwide during the two-year building
face almost 4,000 our pipeline
construction jobs but the pipeline is
only expected to create 35 permanent
jobs as for oil profits a recent report
forecasts a razor thin profit for oil
companies why the recent shale boom
created a glut of oil in the north
central United States dragging down
prices but if oil from the tar sands can
make it to the Gulf Coast by the
pipeline it competes against the Mexican
crude benchmark that's projected at
eighty-nine dollars a barrel in 2015 if
it stayed in Canada the projected
benchmark is 69 dollars that's a twenty
dollar difference but not so fast that
twenty dollar premium doesn't
necessarily mean big profits Canada's
heavy crew to some of the most expensive
to produce it needs to fetch at least 65
dollars a barrel just to break even add
in transport costs including extra
lubricants needed to get it through the
pipeline and the profit margin drops to
just five dollars and fifty cents a
barrel in the Mexican market in 2015 and
if the pipeline doesn't get approved for
the winners
transcanada owner of the proposed
pipeline stands to lose a lot the
company has sunk 2.3 billion dollars
into the Keystone project and companies
like Suncor Energy cenovus energy and
ConocoPhillips could also face hurdles
getting their product to market the next
best option railroad 150,000 barrels of
oil a day is moved by train from Canada
and that's expected to increase to
360,000 barrels a day by the end of 2014
but rail is much pricier than the
pipeline and that means rail investors
like Warren Buffett could win big longer
the pipeline gets pushed back to hire
the demand for rail